self-esteem is the key to high
performance it's not work if you love
what you're doing but does that look
like your group yeah if you left at the
engineers no car would ever come off the
assembly line focus on the few not the
many and most of you don't believe
passionately in what you're doing what
get measured gets accomplished you just
gotta do it but I'm high on life I
always have been higher in life when
they look in the mirror Brian they don't
like what they see he's a Hispanic
American businessman entrepreneur mentor
and business coach he's the author of
the popular book your first hundred
million he's known for his seven-day
castle seminar on quantum leap advantage
he's Dan Pena and here his top 10 rules
for success and to practice success
before you're successful one of the
stories and I know Peter remembers that
before I had any money I used to go to
the rolls-royce dealers and sit in the
cars and smell the leather touch the
leather okay and these days this is 40
years ago I went to million dollar
houses and my wife and I would walk
through the house and they'd say one of
your parents getting here kids no we are
the buyers okay and to get used to it
and that's the reason the castle is so
effective and the reason I stopped
giving outside seminars is that the
success rate is almost five times
greater going to the castle having a
butler wait on you dressing thinking
more of yourself because self-esteem is
the key to high performance if we feel
good about ourselves and we hang around
with people the average of the five
people that we are mostly around is who
we turn out to be follow you follow what
you're passionate about what you love
you if it's not work if you love what
you're doing okay
most people when I say they're living
quiet lies the desperation is because
they're involved in the business or
and/or a job that they don't enjoy they
don't they're not passionate about okay
so if you found something that you're
passionate about then it doesn't matter
if you work three hours a day or 13
hours a day that's where you start and
most people aren't there most people
have to find that but does that look
like your group yeah doesn't look like
your group
I mean in no way shape manner or form
you know maybe if we had a bunch of
bunny rabbits running there or it's
unbelievable but again you are who you
hang around with you know and as Oprah
Winfrey says and which I talk about a
lot is that you want people with a like
mind and that are better than you
smarter than you more intelligent you to
get on your bus don't be so concerned
about what you're going to do with those
people but you want to you know the
joint brain is you know there's nothing
the joint brain collective brain or
brains can't overcome and I give the
example of the atomic bomb Manhattan
Project and they were put together and
they were told we need we need to
develop a weapon of mass destruction
which they didn't call it that back in
those days in the middle 40s to end the
war in the Pacific
and they did they didn't know if it was
implode or explode but they did but if
your if your team doesn't look like that
then you should I won't say you should
give serious thought you should just
change perfection equals paralysis
okay so debt you you can never make a
perfect to say no no if you left at the
engineers no car would ever come off the
assembly line no car would ever come off
the assembly line and I've been in
business with enough engineers I can
tell attest to that with my hand on my
heart they'd still be trying to trying
to make it better
and internet business is very much the
same the internet kids want a test and
test and test and they will want the the
landing page to be this and roll it out
the great thing about the internet is
your results are instantaneous and you
can make changes instant correct I mean
if if something that I'm over seen at
the Concord level 60,000 feet doesn't
work in two days
can it forget about it and move on and
today at our meeting now the young kids
are we ran a three days sir and we
closed it down and they are thinking I'm
going to ask why I said
that's fine next because without them
making mistakes and without them being
allowed to make the decision they never
get any better and in 95% of the time I
know probably better than they do but
we're never been you know we're never
going to be able to know everything or
have them know everything unless and
they will never know everything but
unless they makes mistakes and make
mistakes and get comfortable with making
mistakes
Klauss quits the famous Prussian general
said focus on the few not the many and
the one biggest common the most common
error that I see in successful
reasonably successful business men and
women are that they try to do too many
things and focus on the few not the many
most of you lack the skills to sell your
vision with clarity because you don't
practice and and the travesty Willie is
is because you don't believe enough in
it you just don't
and if what you're trying to finance
isn't your dream isn't your vision I
mean the banker or the person on the
other side of the table sees to it
clearly they know just absolutely
definitively because at the end of the
day they want to feel down deep inside
warm and fuzzy that this person or this
person will do whatever it takes to pay
me back the money and if you don't
believe with all your heart then you're
not going to you know go that extra mile
that's what they want to believe and
most of you don't believe passionately
in what you're doing and that's why it's
very easy for me to say you ought to
turn the damn key just walk away and
look for something that you can
passionately believe in is that so
difficult another one of my great
influencers is Toyota Toyota automobile
he wrote a book called the Toyota Way
and he said constant supervised stress
constant supervised actually I think he
used the word organized stress what does
that mean it means keep people
accountable just like Peter sage says
right keep people what get measured gets
accomplished and I have signs in most of
the business I'm involved in when you
walk in the door that's a big thing
about as big as that paint painting
they're what gets measured gets
accomplished right without measurement
you're just fooling yourself okay the
question is do you the person asking the
question have what it takes to do what
Dan did and you never know but Nolan
guys know initially upfront you have to
try you have to swing at the plate you
have to you know take risk you have to
be willing to sacrifice you have to be
one of the great commitment and just
undo it I keep saying that I mean it's
it's simplistic it sounds like
you know I haven't thought the question
Jim but that's not the point at all the
point is after twenty-one years of
coaching and after almost 45 years of
doing as myself and being
high-performance person in six decades I
realized you just got to do it but I'm
high on life okay okay and that became
popular in the 60s when everybody is on
LSD
right okay but I'm high on life I always
have been higher in life I've got a lot
of energy the same energy of today's I
did 30 years ago you're naturally a
positive person I'm a hundred percent
positive I've got you know the most
contagious thing in the world isn't a
positive action it's a negative thought
a negative thought and because you can
that can grow geometrically and kill
deals kill you even companies for that
matter and so but I'm extremely positive
and I tell people one of the things that
you need to do and I'm stealing my
thunder as you need to be more selfish
me you as an individual Jesus all right
I'm not national no no nobody is okay
because you can't love somebody or love
what you're doing unless you love
yourself in most people and I have got a
whole section on this when they look in
the mirror Brian they don't like what
they see
I'm bald I'm too wrinkled my tits are
too small my tits are too big my ass is
to the my idiot I've got what he call
when you get pillar acne I've got this
you know my shoulders aren't wide enough
you know
nobody likes nobody not nobody but many
people don't like what they see when
they look in the mirror so you got so
you get them to to be more selfish and
to like themselves more yeah I love we
don't want like love love thank you so
much for watching I made this video
because Nouman Russia asked me to so
there's a famous entrepreneur that you
want me to profile next leave it in the
comments below and I'll see what I can
do I'd also love to know which of Dan
Pena's top 10 rules hit you the hardest
leave in the comments and I'll join in
the discussion thank you so much for
watching continue to believe and I'll
see you soon